aquí hay algo que solía confundirme si
tienes dos cargas y les voy a dar un
nombre llamaré a esta q 1 y a esta q 2
si tienes estas dos cargas una cerca de
la otra y las dejas en libertad van a
apartarse porque se repelen entre sí
como las cargas se repelen entonces la
carga q 2 se apartará hacia la derecha y
la carga q no se va a apartar hacia la
izquierda van a empezar a ganar energía
cinética van a empezar a acelerar pero
si estas cargas están ganando energía
cinética de donde viene esa energía
quiero decir que si creen en la
conservación de la energía esta energía
tiene que venir de algún lado así que de
dónde viene esa energía cuál es la
fuente de esta energía cinética bueno la
fuente es la energía potencial eléctrica
digamos que la energía potencial
eléctrica se está convirtiendo en
energía cinética así que originalmente
en este sistema había energía potencial
eléctrica y luego había menos energía
potencial eléctrica pero más energía
cinética de modo que mientras la energía
potencial eléctrica
y la energía cinética se incrementa pero
la energía total en el sistema este
sistema de dos cargas permanece igual
así que la energía cinética proviene de
la energía potencial eléctrica y la
letra que generalmente usan los físicos
para representar la energía potencial es
una y porque se usa la uv para la
energía potencial no lo sé ep podría
haber tenido más sentido porque son las
dos primeras letras de las palabras
energía potencial pero más a menudo lo
verás así y pondré una es subíndice para
que sepamos que estamos hablando de
energía potencial eléctrica y no la
energía potencial gravitacional hasta
aquí todo está bien tenemos energía
potencial convirtiéndose en energía
cinética bueno conocemos la fórmula de
la energía cinética de estas cargas
podemos encontrar la energía cinética de
estas cargas multiplicando un medio por
la masa de una de las cargas por la
velocidad de una de las cargas elevada
al cuadrado cuál es la fórmula para
encontrar la energía potencial eléctrica
entre esas cargas
si tienes dos o más cargas una cerca de
la otra existe alguna fórmula para
encontrar cuánta energía potencial
eléctrica hay en el sistema
bueno la buena noticia es que si hay una
fórmula que te permite calcular esto la
mala noticia es que para derivarla
requieres cálculo así que no voy a hacer
el ejercicio de cálculo en este vídeo ya
hay un vídeo de esto pero en este vídeo
voy a mencionar el resultado para
mostrarles cómo usarla les voy a dar un
recorrido por así decirlo por esta
fórmula la fórmula se ve así para
obtener la energía potencial eléctrica
entre dos cargas tomamos acá que es la
constante eléctrica la multiplicamos por
una de las cargas y luego la
multiplicamos por la otra carga y las
dividimos entre la distancia de las
cargas a la que llamaremos r la
distancia de centro al centro de las
cargas debe ser desde el centro de una
carga hasta el centro de la otra esta
distancia es r no la elevamos al
cuadrado en muchas de estas fórmulas por
ejemplo a la ley de colom la r siempre
se eleva al cuadrado para los campos
eléctricos la rc
al cuadrado pero para la energía
potencial está r no se eleva al cuadrado
básicamente para encontrar esta fórmula
derivando del cálculo debes hacer una
integral esa integral cambia la r al
cuadrado por una r en la parte de abajo
así que no traten de elevarla al
cuadrado esta vez es sólo una r
esto es todo esta es la fórmula para
calcular la energía potencial eléctrica
entre dos cargas y aquí hay algo que
solía confundirme me preguntaba si la
energía potencial eléctrica es de la
carga q no o si es la energía potencial
eléctrica de la carga q 2 bueno la mejor
manera de pensar en esto es que es la
energía potencial eléctrica del sistema
de cargas así que necesitas dos cargas
para tener energía potencial si sólo
tienes una carga no habría energía
potencial así que piensa en esta energía
potencial como la energía potencial que
existe en este sistema de cargas ya que
esta es la energía potencial eléctrica y
las unidades de energía son jules si
estás usando unidades del sistema
internacional está también se miden
jules
algo que también es importante saber es
que esta energía potencial eléctrica es
un escalar lo que significa que no es un
vector esta energía no tiene dirección
es simplemente un número con una unidad
que nos dice que tanta energía potencial
hay en este sistema
en otras palabras estas son buenas
noticias cuando tienes vectores los
tienes que descomponer en pedazos y
potencialmente tienes problemas con los
componentes tienes que averiguar qué
tanto apunta hacia la derecha y qué
tanto apunta hacia arriba pero este no
es el caso de la energía potencial
eléctrica no tiene dirección así que
nunca tendrás componentes de esta
energía simplemente es la energía
potencial eléctrica de modo que como
usas esta fórmula como son los problemas
vamos a hacer un problema simple para
darte una pista de cómo se debe usar
esta ecuación en un problema dado muy
bien para nuestro problema de ejemplo
digamos que conocemos los valores de las
cargas y digamos que parten del reposo
separadas por una distancia de tres
centímetros y después de liberarlas de
reposo las dejas apartarse una distancia
de 12
metros y necesitamos saber otra cosa
necesitamos conocer la masa de cada una
de las cargas así que digamos que cada
una de las cargas es de un kilogramo
solo para hacer las cuentas simples
entonces lo que queremos saber es qué
tan rápido se están moviendo estas
cargas una vez que estén a 12
centímetros una de la otra q 1 en azul
se va a mover hacia la izquierda y q 2
se va a mover hacia la derecha qué tan
rápido se están moviendo y para calcular
esto vamos a usar la conservación de la
energía para nuestro sistema de energía
incluiremos dos cargas y diremos que si
hemos incluido todo nuestro sistema
entonces la energía inicial total de
nuestro sistema va a ser igual a la
energía final total del sistema qué tipo
de energía tiene nuestro sistema al
inicio bueno inicialmente el sistema
empieza en reposo así que no hay energía
cinética para empezar sólo habrá energía
potencial eléctrica para empezar de modo
que le llamaremos
y esto va a ser igual a la energía final
una vez que estén a 12 centímetros de
distancia así que cuanto más lejos estén
tendrán menos energía potencial
eléctrica pero aún tendrán algo de
energía potencial llamaremos a eso un
final ahora se van a estar moviendo y
debido a que estas cargas se están
moviendo van a tener energía cinética
más la energía cinética de nuestro
sistema
entonces usamos nuestra fórmula para la
energía potencial eléctrica y obtenemos
que la energía potencial eléctrica
inicial va a ser igual a 9 por 10 a la
novena potencia que es la constante
eléctrica k por la carga de q1 que es
igual a 4 micro coloms un micro es igual
a 10 a la menos 6 así que lo cambiamos a
colom normales y luego lo multiplicamos
por q 2 que es igual a 2 micro cool oms
esto sería 2 por 10 a la menos 6
dividido entre la distancia bueno esta
es la energía potencial eléctrica
inicial esta sería la distancia entre
ellas
del centro a centro tres centímetros
pero no puedo poner 3
esto está en centímetros y si quiero que
mis unidades sean jules para que obtenga
la velocidad de metros por segundo tengo
que convertir esto en metros y tres
centímetros es igual a 0.03 metros lo
divides entre 100 porque hay 100
centímetros en un metro y no la elevamos
al cuadrado la erre de aquí abajo no se
eleva al cuadrado así que no la lbs al
cuadrado de modo que va a ser igual a
otro término como este lo voy a copiar y
pegar la única diferencia es que ahora
este término es la energía potencial
eléctrica final bueno el valor de acá es
el mismo el valor de cada una de las
cargas es el mismo la única cosa que es
diferente es que después de que se
alejaron la distancia ya no es de tres
centímetros entre ellas sino que están a
12 centímetros así que ponemos 0.12
metros ya que 12 centímetros es igual a
0.12 metros y luego tenemos que sumar la
energía cinética
por ahora solo le voy a llamar acá a la
energía cinética total del sistema
después de que alcanzaron los 12
centímetros bueno si calculas estos
términos si multiplicas todo esto del
lado izquierdo obtienes 2.4 jules de
energía potencial eléctrica inicial y
esto es igual a si calculas todo lo de
este término multiplicas las cargas y
las divides / 0.12 y multiplicas por 9
por 10 a la novena potencia obtiene 0.6
jules energía potencial eléctrica
después de que se separaron 12
centímetros más la energía cinética del
sistema así que podemos reemplazar esta
energía cinética de nuestro sistema con
la fórmula de energía cinética que es
igual a un medio por m por b al cuadrado
pero aquí está el problema
estas dos cargas se están moviendo así
que si queremos resolver esto
correctamente debemos tener en cuenta
que ambas cargas tienen energía cinética
no sólo una de ellas si solamente pongo
un medio por un kilogramo por b al
cuadrado obtendría una respuesta
equivocada
que habría ignorado el hecho de que la
otra carga también tiene energía
cinética así que podemos hacer una de
dos cosas
dado que estas masas son iguales van a
tener la misma velocidad y eso significa
que podemos escribir esta masa como dos
kilogramos por la velocidad común al
cuadrado o podría simplemente escribir
dos términos uno para cada una de las
cargas esto es un poco más seguro voy a
hacerlo es más fácil conceptualmente
pensar de esta manera muy bien voy a
resolverlo 2.4 menos 0.6 es igual a 1.8
jules y esto es igual a un medio por un
kilogramo por la velocidad al cuadrado
de la segunda partícula más un medio por
un kilogramo por la velocidad al
cuadrado de la primera partícula aquí es
donde tenemos que utilizar este
argumento como estos tienen la misma
masa se van a mover a la misma velocidad
un medio de b al cuadrado más un medio
de b al cuadrado que simplemente es b al
cuadrado porque una mitad debe al
cuadrado más una mitad debe al cuadrado
es un entero de b
ahora probablemente digan espera un
momento esta carga es mayor aunque tenga
la misma masa que esta otra carga no se
movería más rápido dado que la carga es
mayor no las fuerzas que estas cargas
van a ejercer una sobre otras es siempre
la misma incluso si tienen diferentes
cargas
esto no es intuitivo pero es cierto la
tercera ley de newton nos dice que esto
es cierto así que si ejercen la misma
fuerza una sobre la otra en la misma
distancia entonces harán la misma
cantidad de trabajo entre ellas y si
tienen la misma masa
eso significa que van a terminar a la
misma velocidad cada una así que van a
tener la misma velocidad una velocidad
común que llamaremos b ahora tenemos que
resolver para ve simplemente calculamos
la raíz cuadrada de los dos lados y
obtenemos que la velocidad es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 1.8 técnicamente
primero tendría que dividir estos jules
entre kilogramos porque aunque este era
uno para que las unidades salgan bien
tendría que tener jules por kilogramo si
saco la raíz cuadrada
1.3 metros por segundo esta es la
velocidad a la que se moverán estas
cargas después de que estén a 12
centímetros de distancia entre sí
conceptualmente la energía potencial se
convirtió en energía cinética de modo
que la energía potencial final es menor
que la energía potencial inicial y toda
esta energía se fue a la energía
cinética de cada carga así que
resolvimos este problema vamos a
cambiarlo digamos que en lugar de
comenzar estas cargas desde un reposo a
tres centímetros de distancia digamos
ahora que comenzaremos desde el reposo a
12 centímetros de distancia pero hacemos
que esta carga q2 sea negativa entonces
en lugar de tener dos micro colones
positivos ahora tenemos dos micro colo
más negativos y ahora que la carga es
negativa es atraída hacia la carga
positiva y de la misma forma esta carga
positiva es atraída hacia la carga
negativa digamos que las liberamos a
partir del reposo a 12 centímetros de
distancia y permitimos acercarse una
hacia la otra hasta que estén separadas
por
tres centímetros y hacemos la misma
pregunta qué tan rápido van a ir cuando
lleguen a este punto cuando estén a tres
centímetros de distancia muy bien que es
lo que cambiaría en las matemáticas como
inician desde el reposo inician sin
energía cinética eso no cambia pero en
esta ocasión no inician desde una
distancia de tres centímetros en lugar
de iniciar a tres centímetros de
distancia y terminar a doce inician a
doce centímetros de distancia y terminan
a tres centímetros de distancia muy bien
qué más cambia la única cosa que cambia
además de lo anterior es el signo de q2
y podrías pensar que no deberías poner
los signos de las cargas aquí porque eso
te confunde pero eso fue con los campos
eléctricos y la fuerza eléctrica si
éstos no son vectores puedes poner
signos positivos y negativos y deberías
hacerlo lo más fácil de hacer es poner
los signos positivos y negativos y esta
ecuación te dirá si terminas con una
energía potencial positiva o una energía
potencial negativa no nos gusta incluir
los signos en los campos eléctricos y en
las fórmulas de fuerza
porque esos son vectores y si son
vectores tenemos que decidir en qué
dirección apuntan y este signo negativo
podría afectarnos pero no nos va a
afectar en este caso este signo negativo
nos va a decir si tenemos energía
potencial positiva o energía potencial
negativa no hay que preocuparse por
descomponer un vector porque estos son
escalares ponemos un signo positivo si
la carga es positiva y ponemos un signo
negativo si la carga es negativa esta
fórmula es suficiente para resolverlo ya
que es un escalar no tenemos que
preocuparnos por obtener componentes en
otras palabras en lugar de dos aquí
arriba tendremos menos dos micro coloms
y en lugar de dos positivo en esta
fórmula vamos a tener menos dos micro
problems entonces si multiplicamos el
lado izquierdo puede que no sea
sorprendente que todo lo que obtendremos
es menos 0.6 jules de energía potencial
inicial y esto podría preocuparte
podrías decir espera un minuto estamos
empezando con energía potencial negativa
eso no tiene sentido como vamos a
obtener energía
de un sistema que comienza con energía
potencial menor a cero así que parece un
poco raro cómo puedo comenzar con menos
de cero o cero energía potencial y aún
así obtener energía cinética bueno es
solo porque este término tu último
término de energía potencial será aún
más negativo si cálculo este término
obtengo menos 2.4 jules y luego a eso le
sumamos la energía cinética del sistema
en otras palabras nuestro sistema
todavía está ganando energía cinética
porque sigue perdiendo energía potencial
el hecho de que tengas energía potencial
negativa no significa que no puedas
tener menos energía potencial que con la
que empezaste es algo así como las
finanzas confíen en mí si comienzan con
menos de cero de dinero si comienzan con
una deuda eso no significa que no puedan
gastar dinero todavía pueden obtener una
tarjeta de crédito y estar más
endeudados aún pueden obtener cosas
incluso si no tienen dinero o tienen
menos de cero eso sólo significa que vas
a estar cada vez más endeudado
y eso es lo que hace la energía
potencial eléctrica se está endeudando
cada vez más de modo que puede financiar
un aumento en energía cinética no es la
mejor decisión financiera pero estamos
en física así que no importa muy bien
así que resolvemos esto para la energía
cinética del sistema sumamos 2.4 jules a
ambos lados y obtenemos 1.8 jules
positivos del lado izquierdo es igual a
tendremos dos términos porque ambos se
moverán tenemos un medio por un
kilogramo por la velocidad de una de las
cargas al cuadrado más un medio por un
kilogramo por la velocidad de la otra
carga al cuadrado lo que nuevamente nos
da b al cuadrado y si resolvemos para b
obtenemos el mismo valor que obtuvimos
la vez pasada 1.3 metros por segundo
entonces recapitulando la fórmula para
la energía potencial eléctrica entre dos
cargas será k q1 q2 sobre r y como la
energía es un escalar puedes poner esos
signos negativos para indicar si la
energía potencial es positiva
ya que esto es energía podrás usar la
conservación de la energía y es posible
que los sistemas tengan energía
potencial eléctrica negativa y esos
sistemas pueden convertir energía en
energía cinética solo tendrían que
asegurarse de que su energía potencial
eléctrica se vuelva aún más negativa
hasta el próximo vídeo